[Music]
you are listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum or baum
i hope you're uh having a wonderful week
uh whether you're listening
days later or you're listening right now
or watching
hi thank you for watching you right
there i appreciate it i appreciate all
the uh the love and the
subscribing to the podcast if you're
here for sebastian
roche then i hope you uh will stick
around
for weeks to come and subscribe to the
podcast and you can
subscribe to the podcast ryan uh on
spotify sutra premium uh
youtube.com slash inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
uh and then follow on twitter uh inside
of you pod
and then instagram facebook inside of
you podcast podcast that's correct
and uh if you're digging the show tell
us about it write a review hello at
inside of you
um podcast.com
podcast.com hello at insiderview.com uh
hello at insiderviewpodcast.com that was
right yeah
yeah that's correct so you could uh
write a review and
write a review actually on you know on
um apple
that'd be nice yeah review there and
give us a five star
if you will uh but last week david
harewood really let
let it go he talked about mental health
and how he went away to a mental
hospital and
god love him man thank you for uh being
so upfront
honest um it was really uh
a powerful episode if you haven't heard
of david harwood from supergirl's than a
martian manhunter he's done a bunch of
stuff but he was the martial manhunter
on supergirl and um
i urge you listen to that also uh the
jason patrick kiefer sutherland episode
charisma carpenter we got great ones
coming up um also if you want any
insighty merchandise
um or lex luthor lunch boxes
t-shirts hats tons of stuff on inside of
you
inside of you inside of you online store
that is and uh the the the the number
the code today for 15
off is
give me something uh ryan's waxed 15.
ryan's waxed 15. that's ryan's no
apostrophe
wax w-a-x-e-d ryan's waxed 15. because
last week was ryan's
50. ryan's 15 was last week ryan's waxed
15 this week we're getting creative
folks
uh thank you for coming to my um
stage it and supporting the band sun
spin every last saturday of the month we
play two shows 2 p.m 6 p.m pacific
standard time we have prizes zooms all
that we really appreciate is a great
turnout so thank you is our one year
anniversary of playing shows
we'll have one at the end of next month
on a saturday last saturday of every
month
and if you want to book the band or you
want to zoom with the band or you want
merch
from sunspin just go to sunspin.com
and you can get everything there it's uh
it's a lot of fun and we book zooms with
people throughout the week and
it's pretty fun today's guest is
is someone that well
i know i've met him at conventions
very personable guy funny uh talented
and uh boy this story blew
ryan away ryan thought this was like the
best episode
in a long time and this guy talk about
i can barely have [ __ ] dinner with my
family for an hour
imagine living on a boat living on a
boat with your
mother and your family for
not a week or a month but a long time
it gets pretty pretty dicey um it's a
great story sebastian
roche let's get inside of sebastian
roche it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you today sebastian roche
we met in uh england somewhere else
wales
actually to meet you because i'd heard
about you so
for so many years you know through other
people who knew you
i can't remember who but you know they
always spoke no
but they always spoke you know
wonderfully about you and
and i have to admit i was pleasantly i
was you know
uh really happy to meet you because
you're not only
super funny you know i but also you know
one
quality i thought with you is you're
incredibly caring
i always remember when um
perhaps joey pants was out of the bus do
you remember when joe oh yeah
you were like you were like we gotta do
something wait
so we're we'll set it up for the
listeners so it's not just an insight
no no but we're on a bus and we're doing
a convention and we all have to get on a
bus
to so they could take us to do uh
signing and meet and greet
and so uh so there i set it up so go
ahead
what is uh joey pants from you know guys
from goonies from everything matrix what
was he doing
joey pants was joey pants was like i'm
the bus
and then he thought he was taking too
long to get there because it was a huge
uh it was quite a bit of traffic jam you
know because
it's right yeah do you remember we were
on the bus yeah i gotta remember
and then joey fans was like you know
what i got i gotta get off i gotta get
him yeah he's like
what the [ __ ] what are we doing here i'm
getting the [ __ ] off this bus i can walk
faster than this big [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
and he gets off the bus and he's going
and i'm videotaping i have this video of
him
walking and walking and walking
and i put funny music over it it's just
joey pants walking and he didn't know
actually where he was going i think but
he kind of
he was like there's this big thing i'm
gonna go to
but he was just he never does this in a
he's such a nice man he really is
he has this extraordinary personality
total new york
but you can't not love him you know yeah
he's sweet he's like yeah yeah we're
doing this i mean my daughter we went
through ireland and
yeah i don't know i'm
and then i saw his age he's nearly
nearly 70 right
and that was incredible i want to have
that much energy can we swear on you
oh i have been and i usually don't swear
a ton but some people my listeners the
patrons are probably going
rosenbaum's been swearing today he's on
fire yeah you could swear
yeah your podcast is great and you know
i noticed how much you
you always care about people and i think
that's a
it's a quality that i always you know
admire in people
you know so that's one of the things i
really i
i was really touched to see someone who
you because everywhere we went you were
really caring about people and it's
something i noticed about you you know
well that's that's right i just that
hasn't always been i just started caring
about people about
about the time i saw you i was like
exactly
you were a total [ __ ] yeah well you
know i think you could you could tell me
your story but i don't look we're
obviously not perfect and we make
mistakes and
through life we we try to strive to by
get to a certain age where we're like
okay i love myself i'm happy with myself
i really i was i'm better as a person
i've grown
and there's certainly times in your life
where you i'm sure you've been an
[ __ ] i've been an [ __ ] we've been
[ __ ] and oh my god
and we look back and we're like you know
immaturity not you had no self-awareness
was there a time in your life where you
feel like you had a little bit of that
oh my god i think when i was younger you
know
i did i don't know if i told you but i
lived you know on a boat for six years
from the age of 12 to 18.
unbelie with your mom and your brother
was it with my mom and dad
my brothers you know we were pretty much
went halfway around the world because we
didn't go
into the pacific but we were on a
sailing boat you know
how big is this boat paint the picture
how big is it this boat is 44 feet which
is you know
for people who know the metric system is
like 13 meters
50. it's not that big um and we're not
talking about
you know we didn't go on a weekend
sailor
all right yeah vacation this is hardcore
sailing
on a boat that is you know has all the
basics
it doesn't have much electronics you
know we didn't even have hot water we
you know it was hand pumps to get water
uh at foot pumps actually
so we're on a boat that was designed for
the caribbean
and we started of course in the middle
of winter you know my dad was like
oh i hadn't i had so we
yeah we sailed on this boat and it was
you know
very exciting but very very difficult at
the same time because we were you know
within i think
less than a year we were totally uh we
were totally broke
but you know what it was actually one of
the great things of being on the boat we
learned
so much uh about life you know i was
living a very sort of
middle upper middle class my dad was a
kind of a ceo
we were living in the outskirts of paris
because i am
half french british
and then we my dad was like i never see
my kids
so we're gonna go we sailed a lot as as
children that
my dad was a big sailor and he was like
that's
it selling the house quitting my job and
we're off
so that's basically the premise and you
know
we sailed you know the whole this was
1977. and how long
yeah 1977 the dead of winter you're
starting your dad has what sounds like a
midlife crisis or
he just really wants to find himself and
have his family understand the real
world
and you go on a not a cruise a sailboat
44 foot sailboat for how
long and and how long are you guys on at
any given time
the longest stretch where you're on the
sailboat without land
the longest stretch was we sailed from
madeira which is
north of the canary islands which is off
the coast of west africa
and we sailed from madeira to across the
atlantic
for 21 days to barbados
so that was three weeks at sea without
seeing
yeah and you don't get sick does anybody
get sick in the beginning and then get
over it is there drama mean in 77
yeah yeah it's really interesting how
the body works at first you are
you know we we were in i remember
everyone got sick when we hit we were in
southern ireland and we went from
southern ireland you know south
and we hit a really big storm really big
storm scary storm
and uh you know where you're like at the
helm and you hear at night and you hear
the huge winds
coming down and you're like oh i'm
terrified but the boat was a very safe
boat but
and uh yeah we were sick for 48 hours
completely sick and then switched
switched off and i was never ever again
sick on a sailing boat very interesting
how the
the body mechanics you know get used to
to the rolling of the boats you know the
yeah
so you're saying that i get altitude
sickness pretty quickly so if i stayed
in somewhere where the uh
elevation was high for a substantial
period of time my body would acclimate
yeah it would actually make if you stay
what you have to do is you know because
i did
quite a lot of mountain climbing um
you have to go up to certain yeah i mean
you can you know i used to do
when i went to the sierras i would do a
quick summit so i wouldn't get
i would get altitude sickness but then
would go up summit come down but if you
want to do a big summit
yeah you have to go to a base camp at
let's say
i'd say 10 000 feet or little above ten
thousand feet eleven thousand is when
you start really
uh feeling the effects depending on on
the person actually
and yeah you i would say acclimatize one
or two days
if it's a much bigger mountain a week
for two weeks you know when we're
talking about himalaya scale
which i've never done uh which i would
love to do but
i'm too old now i think i'm too old
i've done you know big big ones in south
america
but um yeah so you need a few days even
a day or two if you're doing uh you know
some mountains in the sierras which are
you know 14 000 plus
in the sierra nevada's like of course
whitney middle palace say the palaces
there's many there's 20 peaks above 14
and yeah you it's nice to get your first
camp
right sebastian sebastian i get
nauseous and lightheaded when i go to
big bear do you know big bear
it's a two-hour drive from l.a and i'm
like
yeah i don't feel right i don't feel
right something's off
i'm like i can't possibly have altitude
sickness i mean we're
practically just north of l.a i mean the
accommodation's like that's normal
but you would acclimatize because you
know even if you go at the at the
base of uh baldi you know
right which it bought these ten thousand
feet uh you know mount baldi is a
common track if you go the base it's 6
and you do start feeling you know of
course if you
you know you're it seems like you're
more
susceptible to altitude sickness but if
you stay there
a day you'd be fine i think you'd feel
nauseous at first
you might have diarrhea headaches yeah
it's not really pleasant well the
diarrhea
welcome i welcome that that's not a
problem for me let me ask you what do
you do by the way in a bowl for 21 days
what do you do with your br where you
have a sister and your mom and dad dad
no sisters two brothers two brothers
boys mom and dad what do you do for 21
days in a sailboat together i mean wait
you can only fish so much
i mean there's a bathroom in the
underneath so you went to the bathroom
there
yeah yeah so you have a what they call
the head the hands called the head
and yeah and it's a pump pump action so
you pop your duty right into the ocean
right
oh yeah you do yeah in those days you
did because now people have holding
tanks
right that you empty which is not very
pleasant
uh especially when the whole dick tank
starts leaking
you want to have a good holding tank
yeah but um you know you really it's
funny
but so so much to do on the boats where
you wake up
most of the time actually we get flying
fish on the deck so we collect the
flying fish
you know have them for breakfast um
then you know i would i really
personally would love to be on the bow
sprit which is the front of the boat
uh and sit there you know with the sails
and just look at the ocean
because anything becomes interesting
when you're in the middle of the ocean
so
suddenly you'll see uh you know uh
seaweed or you'll see uh
a jellyfish everything becomes
a moment of excitement and you know i
would draw
whatever i saw because i was really into
drawing
you you read a lot and you fish you know
we we'd get
uh you know what they called doradas
there uh which is mahi mahi
right uh we get nearly one a day we
couldn't actually we did one once we had
too many we
throw the so you had a lot a lot of
mercury in your bodies
for this right well it was a bit less
than
you're right yeah yeah yeah yeah a lot
of mercury you're right
probably did you see charlotte
yes yeah i saw a lot of sharks i mean i
was once we got to the caribbean
i was terrified of everything as a kid
and then the boat
kind of changed everything for me it's
it's
it was really the most formative
experience for me because i was not very
good at school
super insecure shy guy
not really good i was really good at
sports but
but but um quite
fearful and uh you know i
i discovered my you know quote unquote
myself
on the boat you know i i developed a
passion for spear fishing so i would go
and shell collecting so i would go every
morning
uh you know and i would go get whatever
fish they wanted or lobster
and i became really good at it i started
you know free diving when i was
i think 13 14 and i could go i could go
to 90 feet you know
well once i got really good at it i
could stay
quite a long time underwater and i saw
of course
when you go spear fishing you will see
sharks
you know but in those days in the
caribbean
i don't know what it's like now because
it's sharks just weren't interested back
in the day
they would they were well fed sharks we
were like it's a different time
now and they look how stupid humans were
and they were like let's get
let's go could you imagine that's
amazing it was just oh yeah
it was actually fascinating yeah
fascinating to see a shark
once you're under when you're underwater
it's fascinating i always remember there
was a shark
my dad was facing me and there's this
lemon shark that comes behind my dad and
i'm like
because you know you got the tube the
tuba uh
the snorkel how big is a lemon shark
real quick you know you're thinking
it can go from anything from you know
from three to
i guess eight feet oh god okay so you're
dead yes i'm like but the lemon shark
couldn't kill us he was just swimming
you know when your spear fishing is
different we were just we were just
swimming snorkeling at the time when
you're spear fishing you spear the fish
then you put them
on a floater and you on a in this sort
of wire and you put them on the floater
so they smell the the blood and they can
get a little excited
so you have to show them that you have a
gun yeah a spear gun and
move them away sometimes but uh you know
and then when people would visit us on
the boat from paris you know
i remember taking one of my friends who
was a
who was such a scaredy cat we'd go to
nurse sharks which are basking sharks
they they sit on the
on the bottom right and we prob them
just escape we get them
above it uh and that shot prompted no
strong
and the nurse shot we just you know run
away but we try and scare our
doing these kind of stupid things you
know it sounds to me
like your parents turned you into a man
by being on a sailboat i bet that had a
lot to do with
how you grew up in becoming a man
because i don't remember my dad teach me
anything
like he didn't teach me how to change
the oil in the car he didn't change me
you know just mow the lawn you know and
that he didn't even have a freaking
grass catcher so all that dog [ __ ] and
rocks would fly in my face
so i know those yeah so he was always
working so he didn't have time to you
know he wasn't a head of a ceo you know
head of a company ceo and and be able to
buy a big sale boat and go out
but like i think did you not learn a lot
which helped kind of create the man you
are now yeah but i mean i learned that
on the boat because before that my i
never saw my dad never saw my dad
wow he was working for an american
company because
uh uh young and rubicon you know
and uh and uh i never saw him so that's
why i think on the boat i by forces
of circumstance you know being on the
boat you learn to yeah
to sail and sailing is is very arduous
it's
not easy it's it's tough you know you
can be in really
tough conditions and you have to learn
very quickly how to steer a boat
how to you know hoist the sails uh drop
anchor
and you get into you know sticky
situations when you're in high seas you
know and
and stormy seas you know yeah yeah it's
it's a tough environment but you learn
very very fast and yeah thanks to my
dad's decision i learned to to be
much more self-reliant or just yes
that's one thing i really learned i was
super self-reliant super agile
i could adapt to any situation suddenly
whereas i never felt that in my sort of
quote unquote civilian life you know
when i was going to school
and i didn't really i felt i fit in
because i was you know
i i wanted to be an actor so i guess i
was the clown that class clown but
it was really the boat that yeah the
trip on the boat and
discovering new cultures that that
attorney you're right into the man
i am today yeah it was a very very
formative
important experience for me yes
especially i love that
do you feel like you're like you hinted
about it you sort of
said in in a way that you didn't really
have a relationship with your father at
first and then he
has this life change this idea and you
go in the boat was it like
did you sort of resent your father for a
while he's not around he's not there and
then all of a sudden you get in a boat
and it was a little tumultuous at first
and then it became this relationship it
sounds like a movie
but like was it you know that's a really
interesting question because
it's funny because it's kind of the
opposite
it's the opposite and the same before
when i never saw him
i did i idolized the image of my father
you know because
he's never there so you you and he you
always see this
you know and in those days growing up in
france you know fathers were much more
severe and earnest and
you know he was the he was the the man
of discipline you know and
uh not abusive at all but you know he
was
much more stern i i had a much sterner
image of him and then when we went on
the boat then you're confronted with
being
with your parents in a small space for
24 7.
so i admired him and resented him at the
same time because i saw
there was nothing hidden anymore you
know when my dad
woke up in our house and put on his
beautiful suits and everything i was
like wow look at my dad
and then you are confronted with the
absolute reality of
literally being in the next cabin as
your dad on a boat that is
44 feet long so there was a mixture
of you know you're growing up as a
teenager of resentment
and admiration at the same time that's
crazy and it's only later that i
realized how extraordinarily brave it
was for him
to do what he did and he kind of did it
for us for himself of course it was his
dream but
he did it for us and i also admire
my mother's resilience who was not
really a sailor
not but she was she's incredibly giving
and
and and tough in the sense that she
she can withstand anything not tough as
a person she's
incredibly giving and and positive
so you see all these things combined and
i think i learned the most because my
older brother
you know with you know didn't get along
with my dad
left the boat at 17 and went to do his
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait he
left the boat so
how long was this whole trip on the boat
and how long did your brother laugh
before he said
i'm done well he the the it lasted for
nearly six years so
within two years my older brother
was like i'm out of here i can't can't
stand being with you i'm i'm gone
nothing against him he was just going
through his his
stage yeah he went and you know we were
in martinique
it was kind of our base you know because
my dad
could find a job because we were broke
so he became a guide tour guide
i was a windsurfing instructor you know
i was like 13 14
teaching windsurfing my mom was
repairing sales
and you know we get like 30 francs which
is what
six bucks and we'd buy go buy camel bay
and
a baguette and my mom i remember would
make a cucumber salad
and avocados because you know the food
is plentiful there
wow so my brother left quite early and
my younger brother
you know couldn't deal with with uh
homeschooling so he was sent to boarding
school so
for around nearly three years
it was me and my parents on the boat wow
i think i'm the one who adapted the best
i
yeah i don't know why wait a minute so
your dad when he decided to do this he
was the head of a ceo he was making
great money and he
left all that he was making good money i
don't think he was making great i mean
you know
we were very comfortable yeah yeah we
had a beautiful house
but you know it was at the time it was
france it was not yeah i mean it was
good money but it was you know
yeah but then you went to broke well
yeah because then basically put
everything in the boat
and he kind of miscalculates it so you
spend a lot of money on the boat
and then uh yeah we kind of went broke
you know
living on a boat buying a boat from
scratch is very expensive
uh so yeah we went broke very quickly
but it was actually the best thing that
happened to us
inside of you is brought to you by nitza
you know in 2019 nearly 10 000 people
were unbuckled when they were killed in
crashes that's 43 percent
killed in motor vehicle crashes that
were not wearing seat belts and it's
always the same old stuff
i'm not going very far uh i'm in a rush
it's too uncomfortable sometimes i just
forget stop it ryan
stop it people don't kid yourself
there's no such thing as a good excuse
for not buckling up it's ridiculous
if you've used any of these excuses or
any others you're putting yourself at
risk
of injury or death no matter what kind
of vehicle you drive wearing your
seatbelt is the best defense in a crash
even when you sit in the back seat you
still need to buckle up that goes for
when you ride in taxis
ride sharing services too law
enforcement are on the lookout
and writing tickets so why take the risk
seat belts
save lives so do the smart thing and
what ryan
buckle up every trip day or night click
it
or ticket paid for by nitsa
inside of you is brought to you by keeps
ryan two
of three men will experience some form
of hair loss by the age of 35.
how old are you 33 so this is coming up
it's coming out
i just told my uh my buddy joe i said
joe
you're talking about plugs and things
like that and you got it you know
why don't you get keeps why don't you
try that
well there's a lot of product it's fda
approved there's only you know there's
not many products
fda approved why don't you just give it
a shot in fact i might be able to get
you some since i
they're a sponsor it's not that hard i
think we make life harder on ourselves
we just always come up with excuses
whether it's
you know whether it's going to therapy
whether it's getting you know correcting
your baldness whether it's
you could you could do things you could
change things and you could do them
quite simply if you just take action
so more than 50 million men in the us
suffer from male
pattern baldness you're so you're not
alone first of all this isn't
not an embarrassing thing there are only
two fda approved medications that could
prevent hair loss
keeps offers both that's right
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months so you
don't have to leave your home and boy
does that make me smile low cost
treatments start at just
ten dollars a month and keeps offer
generic
versions so you're not going to be
paying high bucks for this
discreet packaging and proven results
keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors prevention is key folks
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so
act fast if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss
go to keeps k-e-e-p-a dot com slash
inside of you to receive your first
month of treatment for free
that's right for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash inside of you to get your
first month
free keeps.com inside of you
inside of you is brought to you by geico
you know i don't care whether you own
your home if you your rent
your home the thing is we got we're so
busy in our lives
all right we got we got grocery shopped
and we got this and that to do
but you don't want to have to pay your
your homeowners insurance
your auto policy geico
makes it easy to bundle your homeowners
or renters insurance along with your
auto policy
it's a good thing too cause you already
have too much to do around the house
go to geico.com get a quote
see how much you could save is geico
easy
visit geico geico.com today
that's geico.com even though rosenbaum
can do it
you know i again sometimes i have guests
on where i'm like i'm so envious
i think if i would have learned these
skills as a child and
you know hands-on and just nature and
life
and then i would be more uh what's the
word adept
uh more uh yeah i guess so but you are
you're extremely
on the other hand you know there are
things that i find brilliant about you
you're
you're much more adept at you know you
have a
you're very quick you're very very smart
i'm not saying i'm not smart but what
i'm saying you're smart
no what i'm saying is i know you are
smart
when you're smart and you're really
funny you know you're super quick
and i i really i i appreciate that very
much that's something
and i and i'm i love having a good laugh
and i love
a great sense of humor you know the one
thing
i i became very adept and adaptable and
but i there was a lot that i lost
being among my peers so when i at 18
i did my final year i went back to
france i did it in france because
you know it was easier it was really
hard for me to adapt to city life
to also being amongst
people and and the the pressures of
you know cliques and clicks or whatever
yeah
so i basically was always first degree
you know for me
i didn't understand irony and sarcasm
and i went back to paris
of all places you can imagine um so that
was
i had to readjust that i was very good
at you know taking care of myself
but city life was kind of foreign to me
so you know there are
advantages but you know at the same time
you know when you live
a social life within within your
school within your your city you learn
other
great skills you know that i still i
guess don't have i think
i i think it's i i bet it's a turn-on
not only to me but to like
when you meet women and you're like you
know tell me about yourself it's like
well i was on a sailboat for six years
oh my god
you're beautiful yeah that sounds later
on
when i had you know reconciled
the two be you know uh but i was
incredibly innocent at 18. i was like
literally
like i felt i was like you know
something out of jean-jacques russo's
emil you know
it's this novel about this kid who's
only lived in
nature and is completely innocent right
i really felt like that i was so
innocent
and i think it attracted certain certain
type of woman but uh
yeah it was it was very interesting that
uh it was difficult when i went to drama
school where there is a lot of
in not fighting but a lot of
how should i put it just competition
so much competition and very insidious
competition
um so that was very difficult for me
uh going to these schools because i went
to two three different actually the
first one was you know
to get into the big schools yeah
and you know in those days you know to
answer your question from
quite a bit ago yes i had difficulty
in controlling my emotions i was very
much
as i say first degree i was a bit you
know
all over the place excitable had a very
quick temper you know typically that the
french
blood in me took over the sort of a
phlegmatic british that probably helps
with acting though being able to be like
would you shut the [ __ ] up
yeah yeah yeah yeah do like a hey
that's pretty good well that was my
first gig you know
first gig in the states when i moved to
new york
was doing a play with al what play did
you do with him
by oscar wilde i played john the baptist
and he was herod and for me
for a kid from france you know who
idolized de niro pacino who were you
know seen as gods to all of us
to do that in i was i mean that was not
my first gig it was my first
theater gig uh in new york
that was extraordinary i was
i learned so much from him
and did he ever say anything to you like
hey nice job it was great man
tried it yeah yeah he was really he was
lovely he was really
a really nice man wow very
so you know i've never i've really seen
someone so
imbued with the passion of theater
and acting he literally lives it
breathes it and this is 77 this is like
the height of his like what
not the hype like no no no this was in
93 93. oh no sorry yeah i was thinking
because i was quoting carlito's way
that's why i brought it
because you want to die big time was
carlito's way that's when callie is
waiting
carlito's way is one of my favorite
pacino movies i have a tattoo that says
blanco and
it's my god my grandmother my
grandmother lives in florida her name is
blanche and she's from the bronx
but do you remember he goes te carlito
remember me benny blanco from the bottom
of the club i always would say hey benny
blanco from the bronx was my bagel and
cream cheese
yeah and so there was a whole thing like
that but carlito's way was one of my
favorite buschina movies
amazing performance by him and viggo
mortensen
oh yeah sean penn do you remember sean
yeah yeah
oh yeah the lawyer or something
legrizamo was benny blanco right
he was benny blanco yeah hey carlito
remember me benny blanco from the bronx
yeah he killed him yeah
yeah great movie beautiful typical brian
de palma but beautiful
yeah beautiful movie but working with
pacino man i work well
yeah but to work with pacino would be
just like a dream any of those
i don't know if i could do it i'd be
like i mean i would do it but like i
think the first couple of days would be
like
i'm talking to pacino what's my line
what's my line but you know what
i was like because you know yokonon is
in a prison and he's screaming at pacino
you know you're a heathen you're
uh you know he's like in this crazy
state of you know being john the baptist
and
he's and he's a sinner you know herod is
a sinner
i would just watch al because he i've
never seen someone more
loose on stage you know he he would do
anything he would try anything
i would see him like literally do roll
on the floor while
doing his lines he'd done it before of
course he you know he did many
incarnations of of salome but it was
just
fascinating to see him his work with the
prose
with the with the word is extraordinary
you know his relationship
to to objects taught me
so much he would say this because he
would do it
like he said i'm gonna do it like uh
upper upper west side jewish lady
this pen but i have here
he would do these modulations and it
would be so
amazing to watch he had these huge
monologues where
they were fascinating because you never
got bored because he he would literally
have this
he'd be this this ruby this ruby
and then he would and he i don't know if
you remember he had this crazy
yeah he was like an over made up woman
from the upper west side and wow wow
that's incredible
did you ever see him low did you ever
see him like well i wouldn't say the
word fail but like while he's on
on well on set or on stage and he's
working things out and this doesn't work
and he's frustrated did you see those
things
yeah looking for richard you mean the
the documentary or or i saw him
i mean in real life like did you oh he
in a way you know it's
it's really interesting he reminds me of
that saying by mandela you know
uh i never lose either i win or i learn
uh which i love which is one of my
favorite sayings by
uh nelson mandela because
you never see him get mad he's always in
relaxation
that's every time i see al pacino
you know maybe younger he was more tense
you know but it's this
inner tension you know when you see him
in dog day afternoon it's
it's like watching a ballet it's this
incredible relaxation that enables him
to access something that
where he never fails so he'll try he'll
be like i remember him being on his
all fours with hands up in the air like
i have a ruby
and you know he would just try [ __ ] and
that's the key
just keep trying and keep working
i remember auditioning for then to do
uh uh mercutio uh
and i and i suddenly was like you know
she is the fairies
and i started kind of doing owl with an
english accent
she is and i suddenly approached the
text like he did
and i felt i i just felt
like it it it rejuvenated me
i felt i i felt yeah i felt in such a
great space because i realized oh my god
he
yeah he is he has this relationship to
the world and i got it
instantly and and and it was thanks to
him
it was really all i became a much better
actor
instantly after performing after doing
that play he was
it was fabulous wow and then he you know
he was wonderful he came
i then i did a play with julie taymor
and and he came and he was like
sebastian that was great wow
you know but he they were gonna do
something
and then i got i got him to meet julie
and then we did a reading of titus
andronicus
where it was julie
directing alice titus i was playing
demetrius
and then he he brought in kevin spacey
as saturday niners
uh you know and it was one of the
greatest readings i've
ever it was just extraordinary how many
people were in the room
i think it was just just the cast and al
and uh i always had his bodyguard with
him
what was his name tony or something this
big guy
who was really cool such a nice guy who
looked like uh
he could have worked uh you know in a
you know
in a real insurance office he was bored
with a mustache kind of heavy set but it
was amazing walking down the street when
we walked from the rehearsal space to
another space he we'd walk down the
street and he was like walking with the
with qe2 you know it was like walking
with
royalty it was extraordinary hey how do
you deal with rejection because
obviously every
everybody especially in our industry
that's what you do we we're rejected 99
times out of 100. so
have you always have you had a problem
with it is there times where it really
affects you for a long time after you're
yeah i think like a lot of us i think
when
you know rejection is an extraordinary
thing actually we deal
i think i always keep i always say that
actors are
kind of super humans because they deal
with rejection
on such an extra extraordinary level
they they they basically are always
unemployed and always looking for a new
job but always deal with a rejection
then they get a job of course
uh therefore are super humans in this
pandemic
i think we adapted much better but for
me personally
yeah rejection is very very difficult
and you think as you get older it's
going to get better and it's not
when you care about um a project
is when the rejection is the worst and
what and the closer
you get to the project
it gets very difficult yeah i remember
auditioning for the hobbit
and i auditioned when guillermo del toro
was
was the director audition in london
they loved me then they brought me back
and then it switched and then i you know
i thought i was really close and then i
met with
uh you know peter jackson philippa
boyne's friend walsh
and of course the day i was at shutters
you know super nervous
wanting to audition for that role and i
thought i was you know i could taste it
you know what it's like when you can
taste it yeah and you're like i'm gonna
be filming for two years in new zealand
with
peter jackson you know on the heels of
lord of the rings and
and i go up to the room and i don't see
peter jackson because he's sick
in in a bedroom so i'm auditioning just
with fran
boyne's and phillip you know philippe
boynes and fran walsh
and it's not the same because of course
you want the energy the
the the there's almost that that fear
and that excitement that blended into a
perfect
like you know whatever so hoping i was i
hadn't
pictured you know you know him working
with me and
nothing against uh philippe boyz and
fran walsh they're both brilliant but
it was just not the same and i know i
did a good job because i i
and uh and you know it didn't work out
because physically i saw the guy that
they
they cast and it was totally at least
he's i know him and
it was absolutely evidence that he
should get the part but but it hurt
man and i learned i heard about it
through a friend of my active friend who
said oh my god
he just got the greatest gig he got this
role in the hobbit and i was like that's
the role i was up for
and i literally were having dinner and i
just couldn't have dinner anymore and i
was like you know what guys
i i i i think i was yeah i went to bed
and it took me like a few days yeah well
it's hard
rejection's hard yeah it is it is hard
but uh
what about you what about you i'm weird
i
am able to as insecure and as
i could tell you my flaws all day if you
listen to five episodes in this podcast
you'd be like holy [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
buddy but that was great
but yeah it is great at the same time i
apologize for eating
no you could eat but you know uh for me
when i leave an audition i
i rip up the sides the pages and i throw
them away immediately
and i'm done i do that too i'm done and
i don't ask any more questions
oh really i don't and then all of a
sudden sometimes you'll hear my agent
will go
hey i want to let you know that you're
in the uh the running for this role that
you auditioned for three weeks and i
gotta go
don't tell me that just tell me when i
get it exactly so i don't want to know
i let it go i do let it go but i also i
think i'm my worst enemy now i also
think that i could be
incredibly lazy i don't like to unless
it's something i really love like i
don't put the work in like i should
and that's just sort of in my head i
just like yeah
you know i'll give them what i you know
i'm not going to give them everything
because i think if i give them
everything
that takes away a piece of me and that's
really
it's a bizarre way and it's like well
how well good luck being an actor
but at the same time i'm like you know
i'm going to do a good job and if you
see that i'm the part
and i you know there's every once in a
while i'll go above and beyond
like oh really don't you think 99
percent of the time you walk in the room
and they're like this is the guy
before you open your mouth then that's
why i stopped doing that
i think i i walk in and i you know if
they're like oh
then they'll you know they'll work with
me and then we'll figure it out but uh
i have times when i don't care when i'm
like always
it's not true because i got this part i
worked
i worked on it yeah but you know what
you know when a
part instantly suits you
and you basically have to do hard any
work yeah
those are rare but they're nice and then
you you walk in and you know i remember
walking and there was this whole room of
actors who were really you know
established
and it's tough sometimes you see all
these near stars and
but i you know sometimes when you when
you own it you own it yeah
there are days when you own it yeah
that's true
inside of you is brought to you by
betterhelp
may's mental health awareness month and
throughout june
inside of you is proud so proud to join
the cause of destigmatizing
therapy look if you're struggling folks
i i've struggled i struggle
people struggle we need someone to talk
to
we need to get these things done this is
our life
this is uh it's very important if you're
struggling with relationships you're
having difficulty sleeping or
difficulty meeting your goals
if you're feeling anxious uh stressed
better help counselors can listen
and they can help you betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional
and you can start communicating in under
48 hours it's so important i have so
many friends who
you know deal with depression and deal
with anxiety and you know i say
well have you thought of therapy i don't
know no one can help me
that's always the saying nobody can help
me nobody knows what i'm going through
do you think you're the only person in
the world that suffers
if so you might be on your own island
because this is not a reality folks
better help is available for clients
worldwide login to your account anytime
you send a message to your counselor we
you could message
your counselor you could have a video
chat you could talk
it's it's your way you know if you don't
want to see your counselor i like to see
the person i'm talking to but not
everybody likes that
you could schedule weekly video phone or
even live chat sessions betterhelp is
committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so they make it easy and free to
change counselors if you need
and that's another big thing if you
don't like your counselor you're
thinking oh what if i don't like
then you get a new one and they can get
you one
really quickly better helps more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
it's much cheaper
trust me so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are actually
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy
today you're gonna get 10 percent off
just go to betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by untuck it
i can't go i can't say more about these
shirts i'm wearing one right now
uh talk about fitting the old days you
just throw on a you want to
go to some guy's party or whoever's
throwing a party and you throw on a nice
shirt
yep but the shirt's really long people
are going to wear a dress rosie
untucked shirts are designed to be worn
untucked so they have comfort built in
look at me i mean this is it it really
is amazing i i love this product i have
tons of their shirts
untuck it has fits for all shapes and
sizes including slim
tall and relaxed so they can help dads
of all
shapes and sizes look sharp even at his
most
casual ryan who wouldn't want to unwrap
some of our
top new styles like performance shirts
with stretch that wick
sweat and short sleeve styles to keep
you cool
and of course untuck its most
comfortable polos
they're the official shirts of summer
you want to look good you want to feel
good
untuck it you could wear it casually you
could wear it to a nice restaurant or a
barbecue
you guys are going to love this and
you're going to email me like you always
do when you love products and you're
going to say you know what you're right
about untuck it
most of untucket's gift ideas are under
a hundred dollars so you can buy a gift
for dad
and get one for yourself too go to
untuckit.com un-t-u-c-k-i-t
dot-com or to one of the 80 plus
untucked
stores nationwide remember
if you need the perfect gift for
father's day get him a shirt
from untuck it sure it's designed to be
worn untucked
use code inside for 20 off your first
purchase at untuckit.com
20 off wow untuck it
dot com also and we don't have to talk
about it you could tell me to [ __ ] off
but i know you look
we talked about it briefly while we were
in wales yeah i know like you you
you got divorced obviously now you found
yeah now you found
the one and you guys are doing great but
i remember you saying because i was
shocked i was like
vera from farmiga yeah and i remember
going
what you were married to fear for me
she's one of my
oh my and i'm like he doesn't want to
hear this
no no it's fine actually you know
tremendous actress
you know we we met at the you know at
her beginnings and
you know when i was doing this this
extraordinary series called
roar a roar
is to promote roar for fox uh
you know in which the cast of roar heath
ledger
carrie russell vera myself wow
and some other people so no no it's
funny i couldn't talk about it you know
i
i've now found someone who's
extraordinary uh
my wife now but you know we we were
young you know these things happen
and uh yeah you know and uh and you move
on
i mean it's gotta be the worst though i
always think you know the reason i'm not
married
a lot of people go why are you married
you're 48 dude i'm like
well have you met my family
i'm like you know i love my family but i
look around me and if there's
dysfunction and then there's divorce and
there's a i'm like
i'm not doing that unless i know it's
right so
uh you know it sounds like you obviously
came from a good family and you had this
bonding experience for years and years
and when you were getting married it
felt like i mean i read that you you uh
you guys uh eloped and went uh
yeah and just to the bahamas and then we
actually yeah and
honeymoon in cuba but you know yeah
it was it was it was it was difficult
you know i had my issues
you know she had her issues uh it's yeah
it's
you know the competition enters
uh uh the marriage a bit always um
it's difficult it's it was a very
divorce
is probably one of the most difficult
experiences i i
went through yeah in my life absolutely
see extremely difficult see that's why i
don't know if i want to do that
because well yeah i know i i understand
but i think you know
as you get older you
actually gain more experience and you
know
you suddenly you know you don't always
know when you're younger what's right
for you
you know and i think as you get older
you realize
uh you know you get rid of the things
you don't want
and you keep the things you want you
know and that's what getting old is you
start caring less
about the [ __ ] and you start caring
more about what's important
and you'll when you meet that person who
is completely in tune with you is
you know incredibly supportive smart
funny
intelligent yeah there are people out
there you have to have
all of those that seems like it's asking
a lot
beautiful educate i mean you know
they're just like you know it's like i'm
not all those things so why
why should i no yeah you are you of
course you are
it's you know my wife
ali alicia uh has taught me
so much literally more than
anyone else in my life about
relationships she really
is so extraordinarily
i mean she has such an extraordinary
sense of
sense of self and confidence and i think
that was given to her by her parents
and her upbringing in australia
and and so she had taught me so much
about you know
listening is because that's something i
was not very good at
about compromise you know it's very
difficult to be in a relationship
it is you know however much you love you
know we love each other like crazy
we're literally joined at the hip and
actually this
pandemic has made us way closer awesome
well i would
crazy i'm crazy about her i really am
it but in in in the deepest possible way
she's my
she's my she's my girl you know you're
angry
emotional it makes me it makes me really
emotional because we're joined
at the hip and nothing could break that
and you know and
and this pandemic has made it stronger
yeah
and i learned so much from her and you
know
she must have learned something from me
but i learned so much
and i made so many mistakes sure when i
was younger and
that is what life is you know yeah some
people are like i don't want to age
what age brings is that doesn't it
it brings that wonderful level of
experience where you
feel more secure about yourself
and you start caring less about what's
[ __ ]
you know i keep thinking about that i
keep thinking that i'm slowly i see that
happening with me that
i'm starting to just be a little more
at times i see it like okay this is good
this is new you i
don't know this is a it's a nuance don't
don't get cocky
it's just a little thing here but you
know you're kind of a little bit more
relaxed with this situation you're not
freaking out you're not
and my uh one of my therapists said
something he goes
you know michael i i love this little
guy he was like dr
kessler tesla tesla yeah i loved him so
much he forgot his [ __ ] name
but as he said he said michael when
i really believe if when you fall in
love with someone
and you allow them to love you
it's gonna be very tough when you could
really really allow
i think you're gonna soar i think you're
gonna really and i go
i didn't understand that and do you feel
like
when you have what is it about love what
is it about it may sound corny but
what is it about a connection joined at
the hip these sort of phrases these sort
of ideas
that makes you a better person and makes
you sore do you think that's true and
that it does that i think it's
absolutely
one thousand percent true you know i
think
first of all it's it's support and trust
and and family you know in the
in the great sense of family you create
your new family you know i'm spending
more time with my wife than i ever spent
with my family
you know post leaving at 18.
uh it really yeah being with ali i
you know it took me a few years i was
still my own demonic self
you know after my marriage i went
through a period of
a very self-destructive period of you
know being single
and being yeah you know
sort of uh uh
you just didn't love yourself yeah yeah
and i i i went through a period of
kind of a dark period and and and ally
i met ali before we were together we
knew each other for six years but when i
met her
i was like this girl is the one
that's the one but you know i wasn't
ready
she was she suddenly was like stay away
from me you're a bad boy
yeah trouble and you know the first
few years of our relationship i really
had to
learn a lot i had to learn to compromise
a lot
compromise is actually a beautiful thing
it really enables you to
listen to to listen to
to yourself in a way and to listen to
your partner which is one of the most
important things there is
uh but i do believe that a partnership
and yet you know then love becomes love
is always there
it just it sort of transforms itself
into something
deeper there's love there's that oh my
god consuming love and
sex and everything which is fantastic
and then it
transforms into something so deep
so profound you know and it turns into
this
beautiful love lover friendship
partnership that is unbreakable
you know i'm you know knock on wood but
i really feel
it makes you also it makes you not
question
things you know you become you become a
a husband
and then you meet people you know
because there are temptations everything
but no you just always
you will always be the husband you'll be
like yeah you're a very interesting
attractive person but you know what i'm
married to my wife and you know what
what she gives me is
1 million better than anyone
else that comes in front of my path
so i'm not even gonna go there and then
i will be
i suddenly become a husband like a dad
you know
and i do it and it becomes natural
because
this is who i've become and i'm proud of
it and i'm not one
you know i never understand people who
are like oh well you get married and
then
no my god what a profound experience
i love it i mean you know i'm sorry i'm
diverging
responding i i'm learning and ally with
her support has made me so
beyond my wildest expectations as a man
because the most important is as a man
you know as an actor as a as an artist
so yeah yeah i love sebastian i love
that you were so open about that and
that
that resonates uh this is called uh [ __ ]
talking with sebastian roche
this is rapid fire from my patron family
if you want to join patreon patreon.com
uh so really quick uh lisa h i was
introduced to you through supernatural
but i've started watching older tv shows
where you show up in your extensive
career which role no matter how small
was your favorite role to play
in uh i mean one of my favorite roles
was this role i
played on the man in the high castle uh
a deeply
deeply flawed conflicted person called
uh
martin hoistman uh it was just an extr
it was a really uh it was kind of a
turning point in my career
in terms of bringing everything down and
you know the challenge of speaking
german when i lied about speaking german
working on it to be perfect and also the
incredible complexity of the characters
yeah me too not very much danny i know
you do i i well i have a good ear
yeah yeah so i remember i had an
audition for a movie and i remember i
memorized it
the german and uh for the audition i
remember and i started i went in there
and i went um
i started you know doing it he goes oh
no no no i want you to hear you in
english
i go no but it said in that i just spent
four days learning this [ __ ] you [ __ ]
idiot
no [ __ ] yeah because rosenbaum
means red tree red tree rosenbaum
also i remember living in near the free
frieden's angle and prince of getting
stars in
in moonshine yeah and it did my
by the way i'm jewish so my grandparents
didn't love me like doing this accent
constantly in front of them they were
like all right we get it you can do a
german accent
they were fine danny i love i love
sebastian what was his favorite moment
as balthazar on supernatural
my favorite moment about this on
supernatural was
you know being with the guys jared
jensen
misha the whole crew you know they love
you
robin i talked to them before and
they're like oh my god the guy's great
and they said a few things so
the guy oh yeah yeah i mean robin i mean
you know that
the most wonderful thing actually was
coming into the family
because then we became we all became
friends and we we started doing fan
events
and as you know when you start doing fan
events with
uh uh cast members it becomes like a big
theatrical truth
yeah and you get to know people in
intimately
and it's you go to these wonderful
places so
yeah i mean that was the greatest
experience you know the role was
super fun oh yeah uh but yeah
uh this is from steph and then the other
part the second part of the question is
from jennifer n so steph a and jennifer
ann
do you have any desire to return to
general hospital is that behind you and
if you could work with anyone from
general hospital in a movie who would it
be and why
well uh yeah i mean i think general
hospital is behind me
you know it was it was actually one of
the best decisions
funnily enough that i made in my career
in 2007.
you know i turned it down i was like i'm
a theater actor i don't do soaps
then i i took it and it completely
changed my career acting wise too
because i experimented so much i did you
know a few hundred episodes
uh so it was a great memory great
character
they let me do anything i wanted they
couldn't be nicer to with me
right i love nancy lee graham
uh on general hospital i'd love to do to
work with her again
michelle k is it mikhail or michael
michael this way it's actually in in in
it it would be mikhail mikhail son
because he's
he's uh of scandinavian origin well she
loved you
michael on vampire diaries and originals
speaking of which any chance we might
see you again on uh see you on legacies
i don't know that's up to julie pleck
loves playing that character a
very extreme character i would have put
i would put him up there
in uh the complex characters that i play
richard t all the projects you've been
in over the years which one stands out
for you the most
uh again i think uh you know uh
castle in terms in terms of you know uh
in terms of
production uh uh it was like shooting a
movie
every episode it was the content of
course is a bit difficult
but uh you know quite quite extra
extraordinary well this is
i came up with a new game here this is
called rochet so each
sentence starts out with a letter of
your last name then r-o-c-h-e so for
instance
these are my questions the raddest set
piece or prop or something you kept from
a set
oh my god which one radish said peace
do you know what i i don't
know because i don't think i've ever
taken a set piece i've taken clothes
piece of clothing but when i was doing
uh odyssey five i had these beautiful
clothes that they gave me you know
that i didn't steal them you know they
gave me all these products
and clothes all right so i guess that's
it i stole things
oh what are you ocd about
the one thing you're ocd about super ocd
about
cleanliness and putting things away
super
fun good good see this is
the the c in rochet can you sing i want
you to sing or at least the line
the first 80 song that comes to mind
just uh
anything that comes to mind
it was the human league lead singer was
human league yeah what's his name
fellow keeper i remember uh i'm only
human i'm only and then i love the
midgeur of ultravox i don't know if you
know oh yeah this
means nothing to me
oh yeah i love that song i'm going to
write that down again ultravox that's
right
okay i wanted to be bono because you
know i was like you could play bono
yeah by the way uh h for roche have you
ever kissed someone on the set that had
bad breath and what did you do about it
oh yes i did i basically
you know i felt you know you can't do
anything about it yeah you can
you can go to the makeup artist and
their their makeup artist just say hey
can you offer her
a mint or some toothpaste or him him
some toothpaste or mint
i or you could just say the person did
you just have a [ __ ] sandwich
yeah that won't work okay even i
remember the first time it was a french
tv series i did and the girl was
so beautiful and had the worst breath
but anyway yeah well
that's that sucks e for o'shea last one
ever been naked in a scene where you
show your dong
uh i was naked on stage where i showed
my dong
and uh it was is that the al pacino did
the al pacino say your dong
no no no you didn't see my dog in this
now he was on
in france i was doing this play called
lichange
de paul cluedell and i made sure that
the bath that i was coming out of was
very warm
and i was very happy about it yeah look
at this this is [ __ ]
i also know rob benedict and uh richard
spade from supernatural said
well i know you speak english french
spanish italian it's pretty amazing
how do you say kiss my ass in french
uh we you wouldn't say you'd say that
which means uh go go get
well can i say it go get [ __ ] yeah go
get [ __ ] up the ass basically
oh wow you went extreme i like that
sorry sorry sorry yeah yeah yeah
in french you know we we use slang a lot
i'm learning korean by the way at the
moment let me hear something in korean
um
um that's awesome
that means i'm sebastopoche i'm a half
french half
uh british person kiss my ass in spanish
uh i mean i don't know if you uh
just say get ft in the butt again in
spanish that's probably easier
in spanish i think there's a hodar and
then what is it in spanish in spanish
there's kayate
[Music]
i learned that at school i learned
italian too at school
and i love speaking those you know it's
like italian you know
right uh how do you say an italian my
name is sebastian and i'm the coolest
guy in the world
in italian uh
[Laughter]
that sounds amazing i love it
when i go when we go on fan events all
the guys
like rob everyone's like okay sebastian
you order
you know benedict told me this that you
and your brother learned every capital
to every country in the world is that
true
yes it's true because you know on the
boat
what i read was the almanac and the
atlas you know so yeah
so if i said what's the capital of uh
uganda
it's kampala what's that i went there
what's the capital of brazil brazil is
actually brasilia not rio de janeiro
look at that what's the capital of
uruguay uruguay is montevideo
gosh what is going on
you really are you're bright you are
bright you don't have the looks you have
the brightness
pretty amazing i don't know about that
but well man you know the thing is i i
spent a lot of time
reading books on the on the boat it was
amazing it was my my
grandfather i had my granddad to thank
for that he would send
packets of books you know it what they
call post
restaurants at the male place in
you know west africa and we picked them
up
and then he'd send them to the caribbean
in some caribbean places and i picked
them up
it was great well look this has been so
much fun i'm so glad we finally got the
talk
me too i always love your podcast you
know i
always love you know and you're such a
good uh
you know you ask always such interesting
questions you know
i think i just want to have fun i want
to like when i like someone i just want
to talk
you know the best compliment is somebody
said it's just just like listening to
two people just have a real conversation
and that's the best compliment you can
give because i don't want to feel like
i'm interviewing you
i want i'm almost like a kid in the
candy store going what about this
well dad how much longer do we have well
what about the boat how long were you on
the boat like it's like
it's just things like that but it's
stream of consciousness that's what i
like because it
yeah it's like i'm having it's like
we're having
lunch and we're just having a
conversation yeah it's really cool yeah
absolutely well listen i love this
thank you for allowing me to be inside
you i hope you come back and what are
your
handles so people can follow you and all
that my handles so uh
on instagram and i'm at sebastian roche
r-o-c-h-e and on twitter i'm
at seb roche and that's it because i
got rid of facebook and i don't want to
be on take talk
yeah i'm not on tick-tock i can't go
there yet i just don't know i i i can't
waste any more time
yeah but uh thank you michael it was
really a real pleasure and uh you know
you're
a great guy hey back at you smart
funny and very caring which is extremely
important
well it's important to me to hear that
and thank you so much and give your wife
a big kiss
and i hope you guys have many many good
years together yeah yeah you too and
let's let's uh
let's hang out one of these days i'd
love to once this is all over man i'm
gonna be hanging with everybody because
they're gonna get tired of me
yeah you're already tired of me all
right buddy i love you care mate love
you too mates
you're right that was a great episode
it's just a good story you don't get out
of a lot of people
you know so i love stories and we just i
just kept picking them on it like i want
to know more i want to know more how's
this possible i
i'm telling you i go on a trip with my
uh you know i remember as
with my parents it's just like even now
when i go see i love my parents you know
but uh if i go see them i mean two days
is enough
i'm good it's great to see you i can't
spend more time with that i think
it's not only that i can't they can't i
feel like they're tired of me within an
hour
it's like you know just it feels like
you know i'm not wanted
it feels like i don't think you want to
be here anymore i think we had a hug
and we had dinner and then next day we
went swimming and i think that you're
kind of done
and that makes me feel like i'm kind of
done so um i don't know
like i said i love my parents but good
good on you sebastian
uh thank you guys so much for all the
love on the show
again if you want any awesome merch go
to the inside of you online store you
can get merch
15 off ryan's waxed 15.
no apostrophe and you can get stuff like
small the lunch boxes and
t-shirts and uh tumblers and hats and
all sorts of stuff and uh
also the sunspin band if you go to
sunspin.com you can get
a bunch of sunspin merch you can book
the band you can book a zoom
there um our next stage it is
the last saturday of the month which
will be 2 p.m and 6 p.m
and that is uh that's going to be a good
time so uh if you want to join
patreon it's p-a-t-r-e-o-n join and i
will
i'll message you right after it's a
great family there's lots of perks uh
there's a bunch of stuff i think you're
going to really dig it if you want to
help the podcast a little more
that's patreon.com inside of you
patreon.com inside of you and of course
uh the handles for
uh the podcast ryan uh inside of your
pod on twitter
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook yes please please uh
follow us and uh spread the word and you
can watch on youtube and listen on
spotify and apple and all that stuff
stitcher
uh it's really a good time why don't i
read the the top patrons
these are people who um they give back
in a big way
to the podcast and uh they've been
around a while and
uh how about a round of applause for
them
and now for a special effect sound
effect applause
which one sounded better uh here we go
nancy d mary b leah
s tricia f sarah v little lisa yukiko
jill e brian h lauren g nico p
robin s jerry w robert b jason w
apothean
kristen k not to be confused with chris
cruz
amelia oh allison l lucas amraj c
joshua d emily s cjp samantha
m we got jennifer n jackie p stacy l
carly h carly s jenn s jamal f janelle b
carrie b tabitha 272 not to be confused
with that with the 273
ashley ryan kimberly e mike e marissa n
eldon supremo 99 more ramirez santiago m
sarah f chad w leanne p ray a maya p
maddie s kendrick f ashley e shannity a
lot of patrons a lot of patrons love you
gotta you gotta join us here on this on
this lovely patreon patreon.com inside
of you
uh matt w belinda n kevin v james r
chris h dave h spiderman chase sheila g
ray h uh tab of the t tom and suzanne b
kdf liliana a
water break water break michelle k
marcus
w hannah b michael s talia m luke h
and this is the last list right here
andrew t betsy d
claire m liz j laura l chad b rochelle e
nathan e brandel
d taylor k neil a marion a meg k
janel p trav l dan n jennifer j
wayne m diane r o jetta lorraine g
olga c corey m carey h this list was
once really short
veronica k big stevie w kendall t
lindsey m carol d
ktg sandy b angel m eric c rhiannon c
stephen m cory k super sam emily c
sherry s
coleman g michelle a riley j matt w liz
l jeremy c and samantha s that is a lot
of patrons
it's a lot of patron love we're gonna do
a sunday jam session
soon uh where uh my buddy rob and i we
kind of play tunes that people uh it's
one of those things ryan where it's uh
you know it's a youtube live private
event just for my patrons
and i see them all on there and we're
commenting back and forth to each other
and i'm answering their questions and
then
they say play this song we kind of just
improv a song we'll look up the lyrics
and we'll just play it
and uh it's a lot of fun that's one of
the perks and
also top tiers get like um boxes sent to
them every couple of months and little
notes from me
and there's a bunch of other stuff but
uh i really thank you guys for sticking
with the podcast i've said it before i
say it again
thank you cumulus thank you ryan thank
you bryce
i love doing it i want to keep doing it
got a lot of great guests coming up
and uh daddy needs a vacation daddy's
gonna take a vacation soon ooh daddy's
gonna take a big victory
i'll go see my grandma and i'm gonna go
stay with my friend harland in uh
florida for like a couple days
so i got some friends staying at the
house and that's always tricky but uh
you know it's hard to leave my little
blanchy yeah you know that little puppy
but uh i just gotta have guidelines and
say okay
you gotta make sure you know
these are the things you gotta make sure
of you know it's it is tough man
i love that little thing so much and
after irv passed away i think there's
just more like
yeah the other day i go oh my god i
can't lose you she looks at me and she's
like i'm two and a half i don't think
i'm going anywhere
what the [ __ ] are you crying for i'm
like because i lost her
because she's a teenager huh i guess she
is i mean oh my god
three times seven is 21 i guess in doggy
or she'll be 21 july 11th which is my
birthday oh
thank you for all the wishes no it's not
yet but um
thank you for another good week ryan
another great episode thank you for
working so hard
and uh from my home in the hollywood
hills i'm michael rosenbaum
i'm ryan taylors and uh wave to the
camera
uh we love you be good to yourselves you
owe it to yourselves
to be good to yourselves um thank you
for allowing to be
inside of each and every one of you be
good i'll see you next week please join
me
and right into the show um hello
insideepodcast.com and i will do read
them
see you later